Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Now
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for all things graphic design related.
Go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mockups and drafts of the book cover for the four hour body
Ex-officio Ex-officio and I go way back,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries,
including underwear.
By the way,
that's about half of my underwear drawer right now,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you can also see the viral video that I put
out,
which shows you how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well as every other episode by going to four
hour workweek.com forward slash podcast spell it all out.
Or you can go to four hour workweek.com and just click on podcast feedback.
If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts.
Anything at all who you'd like to see on this show,
Ping me on Twitter at [inaudible] Ferris.
That's twitter.com forward slash t,
F,
e R,
r,
I s s or on facebook@facebook.com,
forward slash at Tim Ferriss with two r's and two s's.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Tim Ferriss,
again,
the Tim Ferriss show,
for those of you who are new to the show,
this is where I tried to dissect excellence,
whether that is billionaire investor,
a chess prodigy,
and entrepreneur or otherwise,
how do they do what they do?
What are the tools and tricks and tactics that they use that you can use as
well?
And in this episode I tried to dissect the mind of Nick Ganju who,
uh,
who I've known for a very,
very long time since graduating from college.
Basically.
He is the Cto of Zoc Doc,
uh,
and has raised more than $95 million in venture capital as of June,
2003 or so.
And they have more than 6 million users per month.
And although nick would hate for me to describe it this way,
imagine open table for doctors,
uh,
elbow.
It fixes much more than that many other broken aspects of quality healthcare.
And in this episode we geek out on math,
which I'm phobic of.
I've had a lifetime fear of mathematics.
So we geek out on how to tackle numeracy if you're not comfortable with math,
poker,
ping pong,
how to write a hit song and the philosophical implications of Moss,
of Monsters Inc uh,
one of my favorite movies,
certainly among many other things.
It is not too dense.
That's the whole idea to try to demystify and disarm the things that are
intimidating.
And Nick has just an incredible capacity for simplifying what is,
what appears to be the very,
very difficult.
So I had a blast with this.
I hope you do as well.
So please meet Nick Ganju.
Hello everybody.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode in addition of the Tim
Ferriss show.
Today is a rare treat because I have an old friend of mine who's got all sorts
of dirt on me and knows all the skeletons in the closet.
Nick [inaudible] Nick,
how are you?
I'm great.
How are you doing?
I'm doing very well.
And you're in New York City at the moment.
Yeah,
that's right.
So the uh,
the beginning I suppose goes back some ways we initially met,
it must've been in 2000.
Is that right?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think,
uh,
you were,
looking for an apartment and uh,
and uh,
I had an extra bedroom that I was renting a,
and I,
if I remember correctly,
I didn't make the cut.
This was,
this was@theheightofthe.com boom.
At a,
at,
at a point where I suppose it was right at the top of the roller coaster and a
lot of ways and housing was just next to impossible,
not unlike what it's like right now.
And I guess it must,
it must have been craigslist casual encounters or um,
the,
uh,
the rental section and we met up and didn't end up becoming roommates but ended
up becoming friends and playing a lot of pool.
And it was,
it was amusing to me to,
to read your official bio for the first time yesterday to try to get some
additional context.
See,
you ended up being the bay area billiards champion.
Is this right?
Yeah.
Who was like a,
uh,
one of those leagues that you,
you join and uh,
ended up being the champion that year.
I played a lot of pool in college and then since we were both just out of
college,
I,
uh,
I had,
you know,
still retained all that skill.
If you played me right now,
I'd probably be really rough.
And the what we're going to dig into some of the other,
uh,
very varied,
eclectic,
sort of Doseck keys,
uh,
skills that you got the seem to have like table tennis and sort of deconstruct
why that is.
Um,
also get into the music.
But for those people who aren't familiar with you,
uh,
and,
we,
we can certainly get into the professional stuff.
But where did you,
where did you grow up?
What,
uh,
what,
what did your parents do it maybe you can give us some background.
Sure,
sure.
Uh,
I grew up in Chicago,
uh,
in the West suburbs of Chicago.
Uh,
my parents were both doctors,
so,
uh,
you know,
nice,
comfortable sort of upbringing.
I was very fortunate in that way.
Uh,
went to Undergrad,
majored in computer science,
uh,
finished in 1998,
worked in Austin,
Texas at a company called trilogy for a year,
but then decided that the,
you know,
that the.com boom of the time was just way too hot for me to be,
uh,
working,
at a larger company.
So,
you know,
like all the,
all the gold,
a hunter's of of history.
I moved out West to California,
uh,
you know,
for,
for the gold rush of 1999,
I guess you could call it.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
and tried my luck at a couple startups there.
And,
uh,
you,
you ended up then as far as bringing us to the,
to the current day cofounding Zoc doc,
uh,
and uh,
the what,
what is the current state of,
of Zoc doc,
how many employees do you have?
Maybe you can give us some stats.
Yeah,
sure.
Uh,
we're currently,
uh,
about 500 to 600 employees.
Um,
and,
uh,
over 6 million people visit Zoc doc each month to search for a doctor.
And,
uh,
you know,
to,
to give a little background zoc doc is a site where you can come,
you can search for a doctor and a,
you can see reviews,
you can see photos and you can book an appointment right online.
So,
uh,
in the way that you can book everything else online these days,
we're trying to bring a doctor appointment booking online.
Now,
for those people who haven't used the site,
would it be fair to,
just as an imperfect analogy,
say that it's similar to a,
it's a more refined open table plus a bunch of other extra benefits for doctors
that it has that sort of ease of use or,
or more?
Yeah,
certainly.
Certainly it has that open table aspect where you're going to book appointments
online.
Of course,
it also has the ELB aspect where you can see reviews and you can see photos.
Uh,
and you can also now a check in,
which means you can fill out your medical history forms,
uh,
online before you get to the doctor's office.
So that medical forum is now prefilled and you know,
as,
as you visit subsequent doctors,
you don't have to refill it medical forms.
So we're,
you know,
we're,
we're slowly adding more and more features that make that process as painless as
possible.
The one of the,
one of the topics that I wanted to talk about comes to mind.
Uh,
when I call to my memory the first visit to the Zoc doc offices and we,
uh,
we've,
we've spent a lot of time together.
We've had plenty of wine together,
played a lot of pool together and I've always been fascinated by your,
your ability to not just test assumptions but also cut through a lot of the
fuzzy thinking too hard numbers and analytics and the displays that you had at
Zoc doc,
the a,
the real time displays of numbers and metrics.
I think we're a great sort of external representation for me of your mind.
And uh,
many people probably do not know that.
One of the reasons I went to,
I chose to go to Princeton Undergrad,
which by the way,
those people who are listening who might be applying to colleges,
I was told by my guidance counselor,
I would not get into a,
I talked about it encouragement.
Uh,
and,
and I think this is actually going to be relevant to our conversation later.
You have to look at incentives because,
uh,
it,
economics ultimately is the study of incentives and how people respond to them.
And what guidance counselors even at very good schools want to be able to say is
90% of my students got into their first choice.
The easiest way to do that is to make sure that their first choices are
mediocre.
Sure.
Uh,
so the,
the,
uh,
the one of the draws for Princeton was a,
it was one of the few schools in,
in the top group I was considering that did not have a math requirement.
And Ah,
I had a horrible experience in 10th grade with a math teacher.
Uh,
and,
and this might seem strange to folks,
but a,
uh,
she was a female math teacher who I think had just been really put through the
ringer to get to where she was.
And she was really,
really kind of belligerent towards a handful of boys in the class and they
turned me off to math completely from that point forward.
In contrast,
my brother had the exact opposite experience in 10th grade,
had a wonderful teacher and he went on to major in math and get,
uh,
you know,
pursue a phd in statistics.
So I,
I'd be curious to hear sort of the origins of your interest in computer science
and,
uh,
and also sort of your general thinking on these types of skills.
I know that's broad,
but a lot of people like myself feared that it's,
it's something in Nate.
It's completely innate.
You either have it or you don't.
Um,
so maybe you could sort of rewind the clock and,
and talk about your experience with getting comfortable with this type of thing.
Yeah,
sure.
Uh,
so in terms of the computer science,
uh,
you know,
I started the way that many computer nerds start,
which is a,
I started programming at an early age,
like nine or 10 years old on my apple,
two c a and just trying to make games,
right?
Like we had those,
we had those games,
you know,
we had the Atari 2,600 and we had,
I had some simple games on my apple.
Uh,
and,
you know,
I was like,
I want to try to do this.
So I,
you know,
I bought a book on basic programming and I tried to make it a couple of games.
I tried to reproduce,
uh,
the,
the game from war games that if you remember that.
Oh,
sure.
Of course.
With Matt Broderick.
Uh,
so I tried to make,
I tried to,
uh,
reconstruct that game,
which is the game.
And in that movie is called global thermonuclear war and some pretty violent
game.
And I,
uh,
I,
I tried to recreate it as in with my nine year old brain trying to deconstruct
where they'd like deploy nuclear missiles.
And,
uh,
I actually,
I was actually working on it at school and grade school and my principal walked
into the computer lab and,
uh,
I got in big trouble because I was,
I was making a game called global thermonuclear war and in fourth grade.
And so,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
but,
but that,
that was the,
like the genesis of my interest.
And then,
uh,
in,
in high school,
we had these programmable calculators.
Uh,
and I,
and I started writing games on the calculator and giving it to all my friends.
Uh,
you know,
in,
in the way that misguided nerds are,
uh,
you know,
at age 15,
I thought,
I thought I would get a lot of girls this way.
And it turns out that writing,
you know,
a tetris on your calculator does not actually when you the cheerleaders.
Um,
but,
uh,
but that,
you know,
that was,
uh,
my best strategy at that time.
Uh,
suffice to say,
I was single for,
for high school,
um,
you know,
but then,
and so my guidance counselor kind of saw these kinds of things too and recommend
it to me,
uh,
that I,
you know,
that I go and major in computer engineering or computer science.
Uh,
and that was something that was not even really apparent to me that,
that,
that was a whole major and stuff.
And of course,
this is in the 90s,
and you couldn't just Google things.
Uh,
and so it's just information.
It was almost like,
uh,
you know,
a revelation to me that you could just go and do this as a,
as a profession,
uh,
and you know,
and there's like actually a formal training,
like you can actually go to a four year college and get and get a computer
science degree.
Um,
so that,
that was great.
Uh,
and so I,
you know,
I went to University of Illinois,
uh,
which is just like sort of a top five computer science school.
It kind of,
it kind of floats in and out of there.
Uh,
some years it's number four and some years this number seven or whatever.
It's tough to Austin,
didn't Mark Andreessen develop mosaic there?
Yeah.
Injuries since from their Max Levchin from paypal's,
from there.
Uh,
you know,
a bunch of sort of illustrious current,
uh,
you know,
silicon valley mogul's are from there.
So,
uh,
yeah,
it's a good school.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I certainly really,
really fell in love with computer science when I,
when I did those four years and kind of knew that that's what I wanted to do as
a profession.
What made you fall in love with it there?
And what do you think makes it a good,
what makes it a top five program?
Aside from maybe the selection bias and having really good applicants over time
start to selected?
Yeah,
and certainly that's,
you know,
certainly every school has that sort of self fulfilling prophecy when you start
to get that you gained traction in all the best kids want to go to your school.
Um,
but I think that they,
uh,
are very vigilant about keeping the computer science curriculum current.
Uh,
and so you can see,
and I had,
I had,
uh,
you know,
I had a couple of friends that had gone to different schools,
uh,
at that time and also majored in computer science.
And,
you know,
I was learning Java at the time,
which was the hot new thing.
This is like 19,
uh,
1996 or something.
And,
and,
you know,
there were,
we already had courses in,
in Java and my friends were still learning stuff in c.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you know,
I think that the,
the new schools are,
are the best schools are very diligent about the,
the curriculum uptodate especially in,
in computer sciences.
We all know the,
the industry and the technology has changed so quickly
and in a,
in a world where that's changing so quickly,
I think this is part of what's so intimidating to a lot of folks,
whether they're just trying to get by and want to be employable,
uh,
or they are hoping to invest in technology companies,
which is a very dangerous game to play,
I think for a lot of reasons.
But,
uh,
the how much past a certain point,
because I,
I recognize,
for instance,
it's easy for me to look at learning natural languages,
which I assumed it was bad at learning up until 15 or 16.
And I can destroy a lot of myths and old wives tales about that.
So when someone says to me,
Oh my God,
I'm too old to learn a language,
it would take me at my entire lifetime,
takes decades to become fluent,
blah,
blah.
I can,
I can very easily dismantle those.
And get people excited about learning a language,
even if they're,
you know,
30,
40,
whatever it might be with computer science and math.
Uh,
I have a lot of insecurities and I can do very basic stuff,
but never to calculus,
you know,
got up to precal and,
uh,
how,
how is,
how coachable are these things and,
and how valuable is it to try to become more comfortable with sort of the
quantified side of life,
um,
at,
uh,
at a later point,
right.
I just turned 37.
It's,
it's one of these things that dogs me as an insecurity much in a way that not
being able to swim dogged me for until I was 30.
Yeah.
Uh,
but maybe you could maybe comment on that.
Sure,
sure.
Uh,
I think,
you know,
there's certain fields of math that are extremely important and just become more
and more relevant every day.
And you see like this kind of,
you know,
like the big data,
sort of a,
I hate to use buzz words,
but that,
you know,
that sort of trend that that is,
uh,
you know,
has come into favor in the last few years,
which is a very real thing.
Uh,
despite the buzzwords,
uh,
you know,
there's a lot of sort of information to be gleaned and,
uh,
improvements in our society to be had from,
from,
you know,
from statistical analysis.
So,
you know,
statistics and probability in statistics or things that are just going to become
bigger and bigger parts of our,
of our world.
Uh,
you know,
in terms of calculus,
I don't think,
I think if anything,
calculus is sort of diminishing because,
uh,
that,
that sort of,
that sort of field of map was more applicable when you,
when you didn't have a giant computer on every desktop giant in terms of
processing power,
uh,
to,
to crunch,
uh,
the crap out of out of numbers and a lot of things that were,
I'm trying to make it like layman's a lot of things that were closed form
solutions,
which means,
uh,
you know,
they got solved through these sort of complex equations that you see with,
lots of weird symbols and the,
uh,
now computers can just sort of brute force,
crank out the answers to them.
Uh,
and,
and in a better way to,
because it's sort of a,
you can more closely mirror reality,
uh,
with the computer than you can with a closed form solution,
like a calculus equation.
And so,
um,
and so I don't think,
you know,
it's,
it's not a big deal if most people don't know calculus.
But there's,
there's,
there's fields of math which are certainly helpful in understanding what would,
uh,
what would those areas be?
And I suppose just to jump right into it,
you know,
if you were,
I this,
this conversation is inspired for those people listening partially because we
sat down at Zoc doc offices to talk about,
uh,
encryption.
And,
uh,
I remember I was,
I would be,
I'd become really fascinated by encryption and ciphers and code breaking because
of a science fiction,
I suppose you could call a science fiction book,
uh,
called,
cryptonomic con and yeah.
So we started talking about encryption and Ed,
you got up and walked me through the basic principles of encryption,
uh,
in feel free to correct me or provide some details if I'm missing them,
but as it applies in a lot of computer science.
Then we went out to dinner that night and sat down with a bunch of really
impressive cts and a it guys who've been vps of engineering and we talked about
encryption and it just blew my mind that something that I felt so utterly out of
my depth with a few hours earlier.
I was able to actually see cogently,
listen to discourse about in a few hours.
Um,
and that really encouraged me,
but it's been hard for me to determine how to,
how do I walk out?
And I mean,
I know you're a good friend of mine,
but you're so busy,
so it's like I don't want you to be my,
uh,
my pro bono,
you know,
like mental model mentor.
Uh,
yeah.
So how,
how should somebody d how should somebody in,
in a fun or interesting way develop some of these skills,
right?
Because,
uh,
you'd look at this,
and this is such a simple thing,
but it kind of blew my mind when,
uh,
the probabilities.
All right,
if we look at probabilities,
humans are so bad,
sort of intrinsically it seems at working with probabilities.
And,
uh,
if you have,
let's say a birth,
if you have a big party and people bump into each other and they have the same
birthday party,
you know,
our birthday date,
they're sort of astonished,
right?
They're like,
oh my God,
what are the chances?
It's like one in a million.
And I'm just,
and I'm just looking at this description here on Wikipedia of the the birthday
problem or the birthday paradox.
And you know,
the probability obviously reaches a hundred when the number of people reaches
367,
because there are,
you know,
that where we extrapolate from 365 days a year,
but you get to 50% probability with just 23 people.
And it's just,
it's so hard for people to grasp that so well to be,
to be,
well,
let,
let me refine
it a little bit to be,
to just state it really precisely.
It's not the,
uh,
one of those people,
one of those 23 people,
uh,
could go and ask the other 22 and odds are it would find the same birthday,
right?
It's that any two of those 23 people have the same birthday.
Does that make sense?
It's a little,
it's a little bit different,
but it actually,
uh,
I think that's where the misconception comes in is that,
you know,
you kind of take from it like,
wow,
if I walked around and asked 22 people,
like there's a 50% chance that,
uh,
that I'd have the same birthday as one of them,
which is not the right,
not the right way to think about it.
Right.
And the devil's in the details,
right?
With those subtleties,
I mean massive miscalculations even by very smart,
experienced people,
right?
You look at something like longterm capital management,
They build this massively sophisticated system that doesn't take into account
that somebody else could have a similar machine.
It would then sort of trigger trigger this a crazy back and forth,
uh,
that would end in catastrophe.
Right?
So if somebody feels as I do right,
that they want to be more comfortable with this type of thing,
but they're not,
are there any particular approaches or books or anything like that that you
would recommend?
I think I,
I think that,
uh,
people get intimidated because they,
you know,
they sort of loot,
look online and Wikipedia especially does this,
you go and you're like,
what is expected value or something and you look at it and Wikipedia immediately
like gives you these Greeks symbols on the first and everyone's seen that,
right?
Like the first paragraph,
the first line of the problem.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And it's like,
you know,
and that,
that that serves the,
you know,
that even intimidates me.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I think I know for a bit about math,
um,
but like it,
you know,
the,
the best way to do this is just start really simple and then work your way up
slowly.
Um,
and so,
you know,
when you want to talk about probability,
like,
you know,
let's play a game,
you and me,
right?
Let's play a game where,
uh,
we roll a die,
it's excited,
die,
right?
And,
um,
and if,
uh,
if the number of becomes six,
if the number is six,
I pay you a dollar and then it remembers one through five,
you pay me a dollar right now,
would you play that game?
No,
not that I can.
Right.
So you wouldn't play that game.
And so you know,
it's,
it's intuition right now.
Now let's,
let's change the game and say that,
uh,
if,
if a six comes up,
I pay you $1,000 and if one through five you should come up.
Uh,
you have to pay me $1.
Yes,
I'll play that again.
Right?
So you play that game,
right?
So now the question is,
at which point,
at what point should you play or play it?
Not or not play it right?
What'd you play it at?
$3.
Very Shakespearian.
No planning.
Yes.
Play or not to play.
You know,
if,
if the six was $3,
if I paid you $3 when a six showed up,
uh,
you know,
would you play that game right?
Uh,
probably not.
Yeah,
I,
I have to start doing calculations here.
That's that love
it right at the genesis of it is the genesis of all math really is,
is you starting from these common sense are these real world problems and
saying,
okay,
well,
you know,
how do I understand this problem?
Uh,
you know,
my intuition says I,
I wouldn't play it if I only want a dollar when I hit six and I would play it if
I want $1,000 when I played six.
Um,
you know what I do at a $10,
would I do it at $3?
And,
and uh,
you know,
the,
so,
you know,
start,
start from there and we can walk through this problem,
right?
Let's say,
let's,
the simple way to think about this problem is,
let's assume in six roles,
you get one of each,
right?
Like let's say we roll it six times and you get one,
one,
two,
one three,
one four,
one five,
nine one six,
right?
So,
you know,
for the $3,
it's,
it's right.
You,
you would lose $5 for each of one through five,
right?
And then you would win $3 when you rolled a six.
Right?
So you would make $3 and you'd lose $5 so you'd be at negative two negative $2.
Yup.
Right?
And so,
uh,
you know,
so you can start to see you at which point you,
you would break even,
which is five.
I'll,
I'll cheat and give you the answer,
but you know,
at at $5 you would break even.
Exactly right.
If I paid you $5 every time a six showed up,
right?
Then you would lose $5 for each dealer roles and the,
and then you would win $5 when you got the six.
I'm trying to think of that.
I'm tracking you so far.
I'm not as dumb as,
I'm like,
actually I'm a bit dumber than I looked,
but that's Sharon story.
And so,
right.
But,
but then that's the genesis of it,
right?
So now,
now let's roll to die.
Right?
And like what are the odds of getting,
uh,
you know,
two sixes.
Uh,
right.
So the odds are that each one has a one in six chance of getting a six.
Each dye has the one in six chance of getting a six and you multiply those
together and the odds of getting two sixes are one in 37 36.
Yep.
And so now,
right,
so now you,
now you could do the game again,
right?
Would I pay you?
How much should I pay you?
If you get a 36,
how much should I pay you?
If you get to six is I should say,
and,
and it just goes from there,
right?
It just gets more and more complex.
So,
uh,
right.
And then you're like blackjack then is this is just more of the same thing?
Yeah.
It's just a more complex version of the same thing.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
if you start simple and understand the,
the conceptual underpinnings,
uh,
you know,
and then just work your way up from there.
I think that sort of every field of math can just be,
uh,
it can just be broken down that way.
You just start simple and not,
not get intimidated by all these Greek symbols.
And that the,
the,
one of the things that sparked my interest in exploring some of this was,
uh,
my experience in television when I was doing filming the Tim Ferriss experiment,
which Ha the future of which is TBD for those people listening and wondering.
It's the entire division at Turner that produced it was fired,
basically shut down and sitting on a shelf.
So
I am,
I've been battling to try to rescue that for months.
Uh,
suffice to say,
keep an eye out,
I may need some public support to get that done.
But the,
the episodes included at one point going to Vegas and being trained by really
fascinating guy named Phil Gordon,
who has a CS background,
who's taking home millions of dollars in,
uh,
in winnings as a professional poker player.
And he had a week to train me to go a heads up,
you know,
one on one against a professional poker players.
And so you can imagine that week was a lot of this type of conversation or for
sure.
And he would ask me these very,
very basic probability questions.
Then I would just have this like,
like stoned a Labrador retriever response with no words coming out of my face.
I need to just be like,
you're getting me right.
But work up to the point where he was able to give me a matresses for deciding
in a very binary way.
Like,
do you,
do you fold or do you raise?
Right?
And then it started it,
I started memorizing these sets of rules and it made it fun,
right?
It gave it a context so that I wasn't grappling with,
uh,
some of these questions in a vacuum.
Um,
the,
the what,
what are,
and I know one of the books you recommended to me was,
uh,
how to measure anything.
And uh,
so some of it I found very interesting.
And of course when we were,
uh,
not too long ago,
sort of sitting in a hanging out at the pool and,
and brainstorming stuff like this and talking about investing,
you were able to throw an extra element into the conversation,
which was,
well,
you know,
if,
if you have it a 30% probability of doing x or 70% probability of doing y,
if the person giving you that information only tells the truth,
you know,
60% of the time and then what?
Right.
Like how does that affect the outcomes?
Um,
are there any other books or even just a games,
uh,
or,
um,
uh,
or methods for making this a fun process for people?
Right.
Because the,
the,
the idea that I could spend a week learning poker and,
uh,
be able to play with without getting my total face ripped off.
Yeah.
Probably 70% of the recreational players out there pretty easily is huge Roi.
Right.
That's,
that's massive.
So that's great.
What else?
What else comes to mind?
What other books would you recommend to people or resources?
Uh,
yeah,
I love poker as well.
I think poker is a great example of,
of math,
of a combination of math and like sort of,
uh,
emotional intelligence also coming into play.
Um,
but you know,
poker is a great sort of reflection of,
of all the stuff we've been talking about.
Uh,
of course the,
you know,
the,
the books I've recently read a great book,
which is called how not to be wrong.
The power of mathematical thinking and this book,
uh,
by a guy named Jordan Ellenberg,
um,
is,
is a,
is it is exactly what we're talking about.
It's like,
it's written for an audience of people that have historically been intimidated
by math or just thought,
gee,
I'm not good at math and introduce these things in a very simple way,
and then works up to more complex concepts in the way that we just broke down,
you know,
probability with this dice game.
Uh,
and so that,
that's a great book and I,
and I hope it does well and I hope it it,
uh,
alleviate some of this sort of,
you know,
the,
uh,
intimidation that people have
and,
uh,
does this,
I know that we also chatted at one point about,
uh,
your classes.
There might be a better term for them,
but internally at,
uh,
at Zoc doc trying to help,
you know,
poor,
liberal arts majors like me become better at goal setting and things along those
lines.
So I know you're a fan of,
uh,
what is often referred to as smart goals.
What would you mind talking about how you set goals or how you suggest people
set goals and common problems with,
uh,
or common mistakes that people make?
Yeah,
sure.
I mean,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
the easiest example is that people,
uh,
so,
so smart goals means specific,
measurable,
attainable,
realistic and timely.
And,
uh,
and so,
right.
It's sort of a framework to,
to,
to help you pick goals that you are,
you can objectively hit or miss.
So measurable.
It means I'm going to,
as you know,
I'm going to do,
I'm going to lose exactly 10 pounds or you know,
at least 10 pounds in the next two months or three months.
And uh,
you know,
and then you can objectively decide at the end,
uh,
whether or not you've lost 10 pounds,
right?
As opposed to saying,
I'm just going to lose weight.
And then you don't really know whether you know what kind of goal and you don't,
it doesn't work psychologically,
right?
You're just like,
ah,
I'm just sort of vaguely losing weight.
Uh,
and you know,
putting that,
writing down that goal and literally putting it on while actually gives you
something to strive towards.
But then the next problem after that.
So,
so the first problem is just setting objective goals,
right?
Instead of just saying,
let's try to accomplish x,
right?
Let's try to get x more,
like,
let's just try to get more people using Zoc Doc,
right?
As opposed to let's get 10 million more people that use doc doc,
um,
our,
our different goals,
just,
just psychologically speaking.
And then,
you know,
and then,
and then at review time,
it's,
uh,
it's easy to see whether he did it or not,
but then the next problem after that is that,
uh,
you know,
people just say,
uh,
yeah,
that sounds like a good number.
Let's get a million more people to use it or whatever.
Uh,
and,
but there's no basis in,
in how they're going to get to that million.
Right.
And so,
uh,
you know,
and the analogy I like to use is,
uh,
you know,
when they tried to put the first man in space was the first man on the moon.
Uh,
you know,
the,
they didn't just say like,
okay,
let's get on the rocket and like burn the rocket as hard as we can and maybe
we'll get into space.
Like they did all the math behind it,
right?
They were like,
gravity pulls us this much and we,
you know,
we have to take this much weight up.
And so then when this much fuel,
uh,
but this much fueled on adds as much weight also to the,
to the rocket.
So,
uh,
so that causes its own set of problems and then there's wind resistance and
everything,
right?
And they did all the math to figure out how to get themselves into space.
But I feel like in business and in life,
people just say,
uh,
you know,
I'm just gonna,
I'm just gonna add this much,
or I'm just gonna,
I'm just going to create this much more,
uh,
x percent more of,
of whatever's going to happen.
Um,
and they haven't really done the underlying math.
Right.
Let,
let's get it,
I think I'm guilty of that too.
Definitely.
Because you're,
you're constantly told as a,
uh,
as a non quants,
comfortable person.
Like you've got to think big and just people who are like,
okay,
great.
Like,
I'm going to build $1 billion company,
and then,
you know what I mean?
Right.
Yeah.
That's a good example,
right?
Like if you,
if you want to build $1 billion company,
what do you,
what do you need to do?
Like,
uh,
right.
What kind of revenue do you need,
uh,
to,
to justify,
or what kind of earnings do you need to justify being $1 billion?
And then,
you know,
what sort of markets or what sort of opportunities are available to that would
create that much earnings and then how are you going to get there?
Right?
You can't just say like,
let's just build $1 billion company.
And so,
uh,
I mean,
it's,
it's good to have that goal,
but then you need a plan to,
to execute as well.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
one of the big improvements that we've done operationally is,
is,
you know,
what I call business cases and what it's,
what,
it's the map of how you're going to get there.
Right?
And the example I use,
uh,
which is sort of just a fun example,
was,
um,
uh,
was we used that monsters inc.
So monsters are occurring.
Is there a Korean kind of theme,
uh,
at our,
at Zoc Doc?
So the,
like the monsters from Monsters Inc,
uh,
I'm blanking on their names now,
but,
uh,
those characters from that movie or you want to call one of them Elmo,
but it's not the right name.
It's a lookout,
Mike,
Mike Makowsky or something.
And I can't believe I'm blanking.
Sounds good.
And just slowly,
it's slowly and then Mike would Koski or something.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
right.
So,
you know,
uh,
any,
team member that,
that crushes it that week,
we give them one of the stuffed animals and they're the monster of the week and
stuff.
So it's this sort of recurring theme.
Um,
but you,
you know,
one of the Wa,
my example that I used to is,
uh,
they have a right,
they had these doors to,
to children's bedrooms where they go and they like make them either these to
scare them,
but now they make them laugh or whatever.
Um,
jeans,
January,
Sully Sullivan and Mike Wazowski.
Mike was asking.
Yeah,
that was pretty classless.
That's cool.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
you know,
so,
so they,
they go into these children's bedrooms and they make them laugh.
And that generates electricity for the,
for the,
uh,
for the city that they live in.
Monster Propolis,
which was the name of the city.
And so,
right,
like,
let's say,
you know,
one day they're like short on electricity.
And so the first thing,
right,
like the first like,
so then the CEO of monster droplets or a CEO of monsters,
zinc is like,
let's generate more electricity and then a bad it,
you know,
a bad way to do,
it'd be like,
let's just try to generate more,
right?
And in a good way to do it and be like,
let's generate one more like one gigawatt more,
right?
And then it's like,
okay,
one gigawatt,
great.
How do we get there?
Right.
And then,
well,
okay,
so each door generates,
you know,
a megawatt,
uh,
lean on each door that you,
you manufacturer to a new,
a child's bedroom,
like generates one megawatt.
And so you need to generate a thousand more doors.
Like,
you need to manufacture a thousand more doors to get to get this one gigawatt.
Uh,
and then,
so then how do you make a thousand more doors?
Well,
you need like a hundred door manufacturers at each make 10,
and then you try to do that,
but then you realize there's like a 10% defect rate.
Right?
And so it's,
it's,
it's like sort of building up from there,
uh,
and,
and understanding the math behind it and then understanding if that's realistic,
can I have,
you know,
a hundred door makers or whatever,
whatever I just said,
um,
you know,
is,
is it realistic to hire that many that quickly in one month or whatever?
Um,
but really breaking down the plan to,
to,
you know,
and,
and multiplying these numbers through to,
to get to the goal is really the difference there between success and failure.
And,
you know,
it's not complicated math,
right?
It's just,
it's just,
uh,
you know,
I need a thousand doors,
so I need,
I need,
uh,
you know,
a hundred door manufacturers that can each make 10 doors in a month and then
it'll have a thousand doors.
And so none of it's,
you know,
calculus or any of this other stuff,
but it is,
you know,
rigorous in terms of,
you have to be able to those,
those,
those into,
when you break it down to the individual components,
those things have to be executable.
Right?
Can I actually get a hundred door makers and does it,
each of them actually make $10 a month and etc.
And the,
uh,
how do you then translate that to say weekly Checkins more monthly check ins?
How do,
how do you,
how do people who take,
who do this case study,
hmm.
Uh,
who've set a quantifiable objectively measurable goal,
but,
uh,
then ensure that they are on track or at least a check in to see if they're on
track or not.
How frequently is that done?
Um,
and,
and how,
how do people improve the odds of hitting those goals once they've set it down
on paper and taken,
say a sort of,
get the,
they have,
they've accepted and agreed that yes,
we need to understand sort of the,
the,
the different numbers that underpin this goal and the assumptions we're making.
How do you,
how do they then,
how do you encourage them,
uh,
to keep on track?
How often are they checking in or having someone else check in on them?
How does that work?
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
So the goals are set quarterly.
So every three months they have,
uh,
you know,
they set this goal.
So,
so for you,
going back to this monster thinking example,
that would be three months ago.
It would be the,
uh,
you know,
we're going to generate one more,
uh,
one extra gigawatt of power,
and then they have to write and then each week they're going to follow the
numbers that,
that you know,
that we're the breakdown of this plant.
So they say,
you know,
how many,
uh,
how many door manufacturer that I actually hired this week and how many doors do
they actually manufacture this week,
right?
And then,
And then you start to get confidence around those numbers,
right?
You start to see,
oh crap,
I can't,
I can't hire a hundred door makers in a month.
It's actually going to take me two,
three months to hire a hundred,
but I can hire 30 in the first month and they're each going to contribute 10
doors,
so I'll at least have 300 doors in the first month or whatever,
right?
And the,
you're learning something new,
you learn that,
that uh,
that Oh,
10% of the doors are defective.
So it's actually not 300 doors generated in the first month.
It's 270 doors generate in the first month.
And so then you add a new line in your,
in your,
in your business case here,
uh,
that you know is going to subtract 10% from your finished product of doors and
overtime over time,
you,
you generate a really solid understanding of that game.
Of that,
of whichever,
whichever initiative it is that you're planning,
uh,
as you add lines and as you refine the numbers,
free for each each line.
And then,
so basically you start to fill in the actuals and you look at their deviation
from your,
you know,
from your projections when you started
yeah.
From your base assumptions.
Uh,
which is something that,
uh,
you know,
I'm constantly astonished and I do this in a very fringe,
Flinstone sort of knuckle dragging kind of way.
But I think if I look at just as a group,
for instance,
uh,
investors,
Angel investors or people who are doing early stage investments,
they form a thesis.
They go out and raise a bunch of money and then they never modify,
you know?
Yes.
It's kind of like the parody of George W.
Bush that Stephen Colbert did at one point where he gave an address at like the
Republican National Convention or something.
And he said,
you know,
I love,
I,
it was,
this is a paraphrase.
Obviously we was like,
I stand behind the president who no matter what happens on Wednesday,
he still holds the same belief on Thursday that he did that Tuesday.
Yeah.
He was making fun it because cause they branded that banded John Kerry as a flip
flopper right.
That's what it was.
And uh,
and it's like,
it's sort of the mark of intelligence to learn from your mistakes and then
change your attitudes of thing.
Uh,
so,
so they were,
they were,
they were sort of a cold bear was,
was a ribbing which for,
for,
uh,
you know,
for brand and carries a flip flop.
Yeah.
I'm not sure the,
uh,
yeah,
that that worked out exactly as they expected
when you were a kid.
Just to really,
not entirely shift gears because this is closely related.
Um,
actually before I go there,
do you have all of your employees trained on excel?
Does that,
is that what that means when they're inputting these values,
things,
that monthly update?
Yeah,
this is done in excel.
Each column is a month.
Uh,
and so you can see the time progressing,
you know,
going to the right.
And then each row will be one of these things.
So like,
you know,
uh,
this monsters inc it's how many,
how many door manufacturers I have,
how many do they make in a month,
what's the defect rate,
et Cetera.
Uh,
and then as a month,
like turns into reality.
You,
you feel,
you,
you overwrite the projected assumptions with the,
uh,
with the,
with the actuals.
But it wa I think in general,
like what I'm saying sounds really simple.
Um,
but,
but people don't do it.
People just don't do it.
Yeah.
You know,
in general at,
and you know,
lots of companies that I visited or like you said,
like smaller startups that I,
that I help out with,
uh,
in an advisory role,
they just don't do these things.
And you know,
if you think about the number of projects that fail in business,
um,
and then the amount of,
of research or forethought that goes into them,
uh,
you know,
in general that that's way,
way off.
Right.
And,
and you know,
to go back to probability if there's even an,
even,
even if you think there's a 90% chance of something succeeding and a 10% chance
of failing,
uh,
well,
then it's worth it to spend 10% of the time,
uh,
ahead of time to see if it's going to work.
And so what that means is if you're starting at 10 week project,
you spend a week to research it,
right?
And people don't do that,
People spend,
people spend two hours thinking about it and then go,
that'd be a great idea.
And then they,
and they hop off and do it for 10 weeks.
Right?
And Yeah,
just to put that in perspective,
that means if it's a 10 year project,
it could take,
you could justify a year,
uh,
in doing due diligence,
which is totally,
entirely not the case,
obviously,
in,
in the vast majority of instances.
Um,
yeah.
And or budget,
right?
If,
if it's a,
if it's $100 million project,
you should spend $10 million just researching it.
If you think there's a 10% chance it's going to fail.
If right and,
and more than more than 10% are projects actually fail,
right?
So if you think there's a 25% chance that it,
that it fails,
you just spend $25 million researching,
uh,
$100 million project.
This is assuming that you're going to take the,
the research project is going to take this Basel success to 100%.
But still,
it's,
uh,
you know,
and,
and in a perfect,
you know,
it's not a perfect world and nobody knows these exact numbers,
but certainly the amount of forethought or research that's done in general is
like way,
way,
way under.
You know,
what,
even a ballpark estimate would say that the amount of forethought should go into
it.
Do you,
uh,
do you,
do you hire people who have preexisting excel experience?
I do not.
For instance,
I mean,
I can read an excel document,
but if I have to create macros and so on,
I couldn't create an excel spreadsheet that functions to save my life.
And how would you,
how would you train,
how do you train someone to,
do you do it all internally?
Do you have a certain course you recommend?
Anything like that?
Yeah,
we do it internally.
And then again,
like Macros,
there are just way,
way ahead of,
of anything we're doing,
right.
Just,
just getting a standard,
a excel sheet working,
just,
you know,
just call it 10 rows and 10 columns is fine and then,
and right.
And you can build up from there as,
as you learn more and need to get more comfortable.
But you know,
again,
you know,
this is going back to the attitude again saying like,
ah,
I can't do macros and I can't do like v lookups and,
and I can't do pivot tables.
Uh,
I can't do those either.
But you know,
but basic excel is,
is none of that basic excel is I have,
you know,
it's just that as I have 10 door manufacturers or whatever,
a hundred door manufacturers that are making 10 doors and you multiply those two
cells together and you get a thousand.
Um,
and that's how you should start,
right?
You should start with just the one row.
So like,
let's start with just the one row of like,
uh,
I'm going to make a thousand doors.
And so it's just like literally one cell that says a thousand.
And then you say,
okay,
well what's the math behind that?
And so then you say,
okay,
well I need a hundred manufacturers that are each going to make 10 doors.
So you make two new cells and you say,
you know,
you put 101 cell and 10 in the other cell.
And then the third cell that used to just say a thousand is now you change that
to be the product of those other two cells,
right?
So you say that that third sal equals the first of all times the second cell,
And then,
so now if you change the numbers in the,
you know,
in the number of door manufacturers you have the,
the thousand will automatically shift,
right?
And then,
and then you say,
okay,
well how many door?
Why do I have this many door manufacturers?
Why did I think I have a hundred door manufacturers?
And it's like,
oh,
because,
uh,
I'm going to hire 50 this month and 50 next month.
And so,
right,
so now that a hundred instead of just being a hundred is,
is the sum of two other cells that each say 50.
Right?
And so you just,
you just work backwards from there.
You,
you just take each cell and break it down into its sub components.
Uh,
and pretty soon you have a working excel document and it doesn't need to be more
complex than that.
And that's right.
And that's a great start.
And you'll do that for a while and then you'll be comfortable with that.
And then you'll be like,
what does it,
what does this pivot table nonsensitive one's talking about?
Is it actually useful?
Uh,
and then you'll go into pivot tables and write,
but,
but nobody that,
you know,
nobody in the history of excel no matter what kind of computer genius they were
like started day one and was like,
how do I make macros work?
Or how do I make pivot tables work?
Right?
They all started this way.
It's just the excel and you know,
that's like the big sort of a secret of,
of mathematicians in general is that,
you know,
everybody started from one plus one equals two and fill through way up.
Um,
and it's just the,
you know,
it's just,
each step is not a big step once you understand the previous stuff.
Yeah.
There's a gentlemen and believe his name is Keith Devlin out of Stanford who's a
very good at,
at,
at speaking to this topic.
And I always find myself sort of nodding and agreeing with him after every essay
I read or interview I here.
And then,
uh,
once,
once I sort of look at the possibility of delving into numbers and I get cold
sweats,
which I need to get over.
Uh,
let me,
let me change gears just a little bit and ask a sort of fill in the picture of,
of who Nick Ganju is and I,
and,
uh,
the,
the first,
do you have a
favorite book or a book that you've given most as a gift?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
it depends in which context.
So you can give,
you could give a couple.
Sure.
Uh,
so in,
uh,
for my software engineers,
I love a book called don't make me think,
which is a book about usability and making,
uh,
making,
software and user interfaces that,
that are friendly to people.
And often you see the software engineers where they kind of scoff and
everyone's,
you know,
encountered this guy.
It's like an it guy or a software engineer that's scoffs at the novice user,
right?
They say,
Ha,
this guy doesn't know how to use this thing.
Like this guy doesn't know how to use Photoshop,
you know,
he said dumb or he doesn't know how to make his network.
He doesn't know how to connect to is his computer to the network.
And,
and he's so dumb.
Uh,
and that,
that attitude is something that needs to vanish.
Uh,
and if you look at successful companies like apple where,
you know,
things just work,
uh,
you know,
none of the engineers have that attitude,
right?
They have the attitude of,
you know,
a bad software company has the attitude of,
uh,
if somebody doesn't know how to use something,
it's their fault because that user is dumb.
And then if an a good software company has an attitude of if they don't know how
to use something,
it's our fault because we did not make the software intuitive enough.
Right.
And we didn't make it simple enough for,
for,
for people to use.
And,
you know,
you see apple,
apple is a shining example of that where they really go out of their way and do
extra work.
You know,
the engineer's do immense amounts of extra work to make it easy and some simple
for the user and they're rewarded in the market and the,
you know,
and so,
uh,
the book that I love witch,
which helps reinforce that sort of culture,
you know,
that that user friendly culture here at Zoc doc is a book called,
don't make me think,
uh,
which is,
a book on usability in it.
And it,
uh,
you know,
it's sort of a simple book.
It's like a hundred,
250 pages,
uh,
lots of illustrations about like,
you know,
could user interfaces and Betty and your bad user interfaces.
And it's so,
it's kind of an easy read,
but it is a treaties on,
on why we should make usable interfaces,
um,
and not,
not just how we should make them.
Like,
you know,
what,
what sort of,
you know,
user interface,
sort of patterns work or don't work,
but also why we should do that.
Right?
And right.
And this is the reason,
right?
Like,
I mean,
think about Zoc Doc,
right?
If you go to the homepage,
you know,
people discovering us for the first time,
they go to the homepage and if it's,
if it's complicated,
they're just going to leave,
right?
And if it's simple,
they're going to stay in and book an appointment.
And so,
you know,
it's all very well a nice of us to scoff about,
ha ha,
that user didn't know how to use our homepage and we can be haughty and scoff
about it,
but then we just didn't get that appointment.
Right?
It's our,
it's our job to get people to book appointments.
And so,
right.
There's no,
there's no room for being haughty about that.
Like we need to make it accessible to,
to everybody.
Yeah.
As a side note,
the best,
uh,
just to choose something that,
that people are also often afraid of learning languages.
The best language
teacher or one of the best language teachers I've ever encountered,
uh,
was of the,
his name is Michel Thomas.
Amazing guy.
If you can get the original recordings of the classes that he did,
there's just a amazing,
and,
and what he would say to the students right off the bat was don't worry,
don't be nervous,
don't try hard,
because if you,
if you don't learn,
it's Myra,
it's my fault not yours.
It's the job of the teacher to make sure that you learn.
So he sort of took the exact same approach with language learning and unburdened
the student to make it the responsibility of the teacher to make it easy,
uh,
which is I think partially why he was so spectacularly successful.
So it's,
it just goes to show,
um,
and he could get people up to basic speaking in,
in all of the romance languages and about eight hours of class time.
It's really amazing.
Um,
so what other,
what other books outside of outside of don't make me think,
do you do you give most as a gift or recommend most,
uh,
and then you know how to measure anything,
which is what we talked about before,
which is,
uh,
which is about,
you know,
being outcome based and being,
getting these measurable outcomes saying I'm going to lose 10 pounds as opposed
to just saying,
oh,
I'm going to try to lose weight.
Uh,
is you know,
and this,
this is a great book because,
uh,
you know,
people often complain
that they can't measure something,
right?
Like how many people like our site,
like if people,
do people really like our website?
Well how do you measure that?
Well its measurable,
right?
You can do a survey,
you can ask people,
you can,
you're going to just look at conversion rates.
How many people actually do something on your website as opposed to just look at
it and run away.
And so this book is,
as you know,
I found is quite informative on to how to think about,
uh,
you know,
measuring things that you might have thought were intangible historically.
Uh,
and it also goes into these kind of ideas about,
uh,
why it's valuable to measure something.
So going back to what I was saying about,
you know,
if there's a 10% chance of something failing,
well then you should spend 10% of your time like,
uh,
before doing it,
you know,
deciding if it's going to fail or not.
And,
um,
uh,
and so really getting that disciplined about,
about doing,
you know,
doing enough forethought and like sort of reflection upfront,
uh,
is another big sort of theme of this book.
I thought the confidence,
it's interval aspect was really fascinating as well.
Not something that I've thought enough about.
Um,
yeah.
And to just,
you know,
if you're 90% confident that something is going to happen or that something is
correct,
what does that actually mean?
People throw that around.
Like,
how certain are you have 75% certain,
like how,
how should that be reflected in your actions and preparation and so on.
Right,
right,
right.
Uh,
yeah,
I thought it was really,
really fascinating.
Um,
do you have a,
what is your favorite documentary or,
or your
movie or favorites?
And these don't have to be hybrid.
It could be legally blonde.
Oh,
I dunno.
Uh,
I really like Forrest Gump a lot.
I don't know.
That's like a common one or cheesy one.
Um,
what do you like?
Well,
it's,
you know,
it's like,
in the beginning,
I mean,
it's sort of a obvious symbolism,
but in the beginning there's like a feather floating around.
In the end there's a feather floating around and he's sort of,
uh,
you know,
he kind of flips around,
right?
Like he kinda,
he kinda,
uh,
I forgot the exact story,
but like,
I think he's like running,
oh,
I know.
He like,
there's a football field and he kind of runs through it because he's running,
he's fleeing from something and he runs back and everybody.
So then they kind of like,
oh my God,
we've got to get that guy to play football.
And then he plays football and then he goes to college because he plays football
at the end of college.
Like some,
uh,
army recruiter just hands them a flier just at random and says like,
you should join the army.
And he's like,
okay,
I'll join the army.
And so he's just kind of floating around on the wind there.
And I think it's,
um,
it's a good sort of a lesson where,
you know,
where you don't take yourself too seriously,
right?
Like,
it's like you're,
you're going to just like,
things are gonna happen and the more you stress out about like,
life is not going exactly the way I planned a rhythm.
More unhappy.
You're going to make yourself,
which is not to say you shouldn't try to do things,
but,
uh,
you know,
you should certainly try to shape your life and,
and,
and all this.
But,
but you know,
don't,
don't take it too seriously or don't,
don't stress out too much when things don't go exactly how you plan.
So how,
I would love to hear maybe a concrete example from your life because from all
outward
indications,
I mean,
you've done exceptionally well with Zoc doc and elsewhere.
How do you choose how much to plan versus a sort of allow to,
to,
to bend to Serendipity,
right?
Because you,
you do a bunch of other things and we haven't gotten into yet,
but the music you need to take very,
very seriously.
Um,
we're,
we're going to talk about ping pong now that you mentioned Forrest Gump,
but like,
well,
like let's use ping pong as an example.
Let's tell it,
tell it.
Maybe you can explain the ping pong,
uh,
the ping pong phenomenon.
What are your experience of Ping Pong and just,
you know,
this goes back to what you were saying about,
uh,
older people wanting to learn something.
Uh,
you know,
people,
I play guitar and people say,
Wow,
I wish I had started guitar when I was a kid so I could play.
And I said,
well,
I started when I was 28.
And so,
you know,
uh,
still young but not,
you know,
I wasn't like a 10 year old and,
and ping pong.
Uh,
I learned when I was,
when I was 36 and I'm 38 now.
Uh,
and I thought that would be,
uh,
it's another interesting thing.
It's really,
I think people limit themselves as to,
they think they can learn or it's almost like an excuse to not have to try to
learn something.
Right?
Right.
Oh,
I'm 36,
like I can't learn ping pong now I'm too old.
And it's just,
it kind of makes it easy to,
to say it's,
it's easy to not try to double down and actually learn something because you can
just kind of cast it off and say,
Oh,
I'm too old to learn new things.
Right.
Um,
but the of the ping pong was that we got,
uh,
we purchased two or three ping pong tables for my office,
two years ago.
And,
uh,
and I was the worst player.
I had never played ping pong in my life.
I'd play it like five times in my whole life.
And,
and I was the worst player,
uh,
out of everybody and,
and everybody was laughing and they were like,
ha ha ha.
Because you know,
it's always fun to like,
just screwed the boss,
right?
So,
so,
right.
So the boss sucks at pink fung.
Ha Ha,
we're all beating the bus pink phone.
And so I got,
I got,
you know,
I got a little,
I got motivated,
let's say they got motivated
and I,
you know,
and I threw down the gauntlet and they said,
uh,
okay,
I'm going to beat everybody here.
I'm going to beat every at this company in 30 days.
Um,
okay,
so you proclaimed this,
this was proclaimed it out loud and,
and uh,
you know,
and I,
and I Photoshop like the,
the highlands,
there's a Highlander,
I don't know if you remember that movie,
the phones,
they're going to be only one.
I'm like,
yeah.
So like,
you know,
there's a soul,
there's a photo of him with a sword in the air and the lightning is striking the
sword.
And I replaced the sort of the ping pong paddle and ladies drinking is a ping
pong paddle.
And I wrote,
there can be only one and uh,
but you know,
but,
uh,
I practiced and practiced,
and in,
in 30 days,
uh,
I had beaten all but two people at the company and then,
and then,
and you know,
because this is like the long tail of,
of right,
like at the end of the bell curve is going to be people who are exceptionally
good,
but,
uh,
and getting mathy again.
I know,
right.
But,
uh,
no,
it's just like,
I mean it's like,
uh,
you know,
Facebook and Peter teals portfolio,
right.
There's just sort of like a power law.
Yeah,
exactly.
Last two people who are going to be monsters.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And so,
but then in another 30 days I'd beat those two people.
And so I said,
in 30 days I'll beat everybody,
but in 60 days,
uh,
I beat everybody but two people in 30 days and then 60 days I beat everybody.
Um,
how did you,
how did you go about learning it?
Like when you sat down and you're like,
okay,
now I run the risk of humiliating myself if I don't make this happen.
Yeah.
What was your,
when you sat down to like plan it out,
how did you do it?
Yeah,
so first of all,
I don't think like that,
that's an interesting sort of way to put it.
It,
it never occurred to me to say like,
Oh,
I'm humiliating myself.
I didn't do this.
And maybe that's like a sort of a mentality that's a,
maybe that's like illustrative of the mentality,
right?
I wasn't,
uh,
it until you said that now,
like two years later,
it never crossed my mind that,
uh,
like the humiliation of defeat or how humiliating that would be.
Um,
and so,
you know,
maybe,
it's just,
it's more constructive to just think about,
like,
to focus on the positive of when you're going to win and not,
and not,
and not fret about the downside.
So when you were
gloating over
the other,
the employees and governing,
yeah.
How did you sit down to two to plan it out or what,
what was the method?
Because I actually want to get good at pink box,
I'm sure.
Sure,
sure.
So this is the first thing was by far the most important thing was,
uh,
I went to the pink Pong,
like,
uh,
a parlor by my house and took lessons.
Right.
And so,
right.
And that was,
and then when I,
at the end,
when,
uh,
so as I was taking lessons once a week from there and I,
you know,
and that of course just,
just catapulted me in my skill level.
Um,
but,
uh,
and what,
what happened was at the third or fourth week,
uh,
one of my coworkers came into that pink pong parlor and saw me and saw me taking
lessons and,
and spilled to the entire,
uh,
a company that I had been taking lessons and which I thought was another
interesting sort of,
uh,
you know,
reflection on life,
which is,
you know,
people are like,
oh,
you didn't say you were going to do that thing.
Right.
And I was like,
I didn't say what I was going to do or what I wasn't going to do is just
[inaudible] you're asking.
I said,
I'm going to beat everybody.
And you know,
when we started Zoc doc people said the same thing,
right?
People said,
Oh,
you'll never get like,
you know,
there's,
there's practice management software that exists out there.
And they said,
you know,
you'll never be able to integrate to these third party,
uh,
practice management systems because there are too antiquated and uh,
right there they're not going to release a new version.
And some of some of the companies are,
you know,
they're not even developing those things anymore.
And we went and you know,
we just went into reverse engineered some of the existing ones,
uh,
just by literally like getting copies of the software and,
and,
uh,
deconstructing the file structure and really reverse engineering it.
And we got it working and all of a sudden,
you know,
uh,
Zoc doc started working the,
you know,
the,
all these,
all these antiquated software is we're effectively communicating with us.
And then those naysayers were like,
oh,
you didn't say you were going to do that,
right?
Like,
we thought you had to strike up partnerships with all these like software
companies.
You didn't say you were just going to get the software and reverse engineer it.
And it's like,
well,
I didn't say I was or I wasn't.
But it's like,
you know,
if you're thinking so inside the box and then when somebody thinks outside the
box and get something done that you didn't eat,
you know,
you,
you should learn from it.
You should be like,
oh,
that's slick.
You shouldn't be like,
oh,
I,
you didn't say you were going to do that.
That's not fair.
Right.
It's not right.
And you know,
that's another sort of illustration of like,
I'd say positive attitudes versus negative attitudes,
but you know,
so I took these lessons,
so I took these pink pong lessons and then they go,
oh,
you didn't say you're going to do that.
And you know,
then they started saying,
only you can afford lessons.
The Guy,
the guy that came and found me in the ping pong place was like,
uh,
he,
he ran into me at the bar of,
there was a,
there's a bar in this ping pong parlor.
And he said,
yeah,
not everyone can afford the lessons.
And I was like,
and he's like,
I was like,
how much did you spend on these drinks?
And he had bought her a round of drinks for four or five of his friends,
and he was like,
this is $40.
And I was like,
the ping pong lesson,
I just took us $35 and I'm not drinking,
I haven't put any drinks,
so I'm going to come out of this ping pong,
you know,
place spending less than you have.
Uh,
but you know,
so the first thing I did was that,
and uh,
and started with a proper forum and then,
uh,
and then practiced a lot when,
when people weren't around.
Um,
how did you practice when people weren't around?
So there's like a one,
wasn't it?
What are,
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna Cheat here.
I guess.
What are some of the most common mistakes that people make?
Playing Ping Pong?
Just like the randos who are like,
have a couple beers and grab a ping pong table.
Like,
what do,
when you watch it,
what makes you cringe?
What do you like?
Ah,
if they only knew the basics,
they should do this and not do that.
Yeah.
Number one is,
is the,
is the grip.
So a lot of people just hold it atrociously,
just hold the ping pong paddle in whatever way that first your first inclined to
do it.
Um,
and you know,
the general way,
there's a couple of like schools of whole of holding it,
but the general you're supposed to do it is uh,
it's called the handshake and so you sort of extend your hand like you're having
a handshake,
you know,
here,
but to shake somebody's hand and then you put the handle in that way.
Sort of hard to explain it.
So your,
your,
your four fingers,
not your thumb then or extended kind of diagonally across the back,
the flat portion as opposed to the handle of,
of one of the paddles.
Yeah.
I mean you don't want to cover a large portion of the paddle with your hand
cause then your backend will just,
you'll hit it,
it'll hit your fingers.
Right.
Um,
but yeah,
that's essentially the right idea.
Okay.
People can Google it though.
The handshake,
handshake method and then,
and the handshake grip.
And then the,
uh,
the other thing is people just don't,
have any conception of,
of how big a big,
how big a role spin is in the game.
And so it's a,
it's a very light ball and,
and spin has an immense effect on the ball.
And so,
you know,
your normal like looping forehand is supposed to have a lot of top spin on it.
And so every ball should have spin on it.
And,
you know,
depending on what you're trying to do,
if you're trying to slice it,
if you're trying to side span,
if you're trying to top spin,
um,
if you're just hitting it flat,
then you're sort of,
uh,
forsaking and opportunity to do something,
you know,
tricky with it that,
that would,
that would screw up your opponent.
And so,
uh,
you know,
learning how to hit the ball would spin as this,
I'd say the second biggest thing.
Cool.
Uh,
what do you,
what do you have any morning or evening rituals?
Like what does the first hour of your day look like?
Uh,
that's an interesting question.
I mean,
I suppose I,
I don't really have any rituals.
I just get up and get ready and come to work.
Uh,
you know,
I think that you do brush your teeth every morning.
I do brush my teeth as long as other days.
I remember I brought,
uh,
no,
I,
I think that,
uh,
I'm very fortunate in that,
every,
every day has a different set of challenges and like,
uh,
you know,
I kind of have,
uh,
the whole,
the whole company is as part of,
you know,
uh,
the stuff that I'm concerned with.
So,
so let me,
let me rephrase that because I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna push a little,
I bet you do have patterns at least at whether it's weekly or a daily.
And I'm just curious what of those patterns contribute to your sort of,
uh,
effectiveness,
or,
you know,
just output or lower your stress,
right?
I mean,
so you,
you know,
music is,
is part of your life,
but are there,
are there things you do say on a weekly basis,
like one day a week or twice a week or whatever it might be that you think allow
you to be a high functioning person without your,
uh,
sort of having to be put in a mental institution every once in a while to de
stress?
Yeah,
certainly.
Uh,
you know,
I guess I don't really,
I haven't really thought about it in those terms.
I don't,
uh,
I'm such a negative person.
I'm know it's like an illustration maybe that I'm not like maybe not self aware
that like today I need to,
you know,
today I should do something that de stress cause my stress levels are,
are high and,
and certainly I do get,
you know,
uh,
to,
you know,
there are certainly are days when the stress levels are high.
And I don't think I am self aware enough to like,
have like,
okay,
today I should meditate or whatever.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
I certainly read a lot.
Uh,
you know,
I,
uh,
I think I try to rid myself of,
of cognitive biases.
That's something that is extremely nerdy thing to say.
Yeah.
Could you explain to people for those people who may not be familiar what that
means?
Yeah,
sure.
So,
uh,
or give an example either.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a huge slew of,
uh,
you know,
what a psychologist would call cognitive biases that humans have.
And um,
what they are,
are things that make,
uh,
you know,
human,
but for whatever reason,
like,
you know,
evolutionary reason,
it makes them,
uh,
averse to something that they shouldn't be averse to or like irrationally
evaluate things.
And so I'll give you an example.
We can go back to gambling again.
Um,
you know,
uh,
let,
let's use the same example.
So like if we,
if it was $10,
you know,
if,
if we rolled a die and each time we lost each time I,
it was one through five.
If you lost a dollar and if it was 61,
you know,
$10,
then you would play that game,
right?
Because over time you would,
you would be a positive.
But,
uh,
if each,
each time zooming,
I have the bank roll.
Yeah,
correct.
Yeah.
Assuming you have the bankroll,
but let's say each time that you rolled that die instead of,
uh,
instead of each role,
losing $1,
one through five,
losing $1 and six gaining $10,
let's say they each have one through five,
you lost $10,000,
and then,
uh,
and then with a six,
you want $100,000.
Uh,
now would you play that game?
So it,
you know,
it turns out that most people wouldn't play that game even though the numbers
are the same.
Uh,
because the fear of losing that much money is,
is a great sort of insurmountable.
And so people have these,
uh,
even though you should play that game,
right?
And a large would play that game and even a rational actor would play that game.
And so people have,
uh,
so that's a cognitive bias called loss aversion,
right?
Like losing $100,
uh,
you feel more bad for losing $100.
Then you feel good when you win $100,
right?
Yeah.
The sunken costs fallacy.
Close a close cousin.
Right?
So you have people,
yeah,
yeah.
Hold onto an investment just because they have,
it's gone down a certain amount.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My favorite story of,
of,
of sunk cost is,
uh,
is there's this,
tennis is tennis club where,
um,
where you can rent a,
where the outdoor courts are free,
but the indoor courts,
you have to rent and you have to rent them ahead of time.
You have to rent them like three weeks ahead of time and you just pay like 50
bucks for the court for an hour or whatever.
And,
uh,
and this is a real case,
I forgot where it was,
but in like march or April,
uh,
you know,
you and,
and the outdoor courts have generally considered to be far more pleasurable
because you're outside and it's warm and whatever sunny.
Um,
and the indoor courts are,
you know,
this uncomfortable,
like white lights or whatever.
And so what happens is,
uh,
in April,
it'll be a beautiful sunny day.
Uh,
and,
and the people that we were playing on the indoor courts and the outdoor courts
are empty.
And you say,
well,
why are you playing on the indoor court?
Uh,
you should go play outside.
And they're like,
well,
we've already paid for the indoor court,
right?
Like we already have,
we paid for it last week,
so now we're going to go to the indoor court,
we're going to play.
And you're like,
put the outdoor cord is far nicer and it's empty.
Why don't you go play there?
Right?
And they go,
well,
no,
cause we've paid for this one.
Right?
And so it's not,
it's a sunk cost fallacy,
right?
And it's,
it's,
uh,
this is a cognitive bias,
right?
You should do the thing that is most like,
you know,
you should play tennis on the most pleasurable court then it doesn't matter if
you paid 50 bucks a week ago for the less pleasurable court.
If the nicer court is open right now,
you should play in the nicer court.
So I should,
uh,
mention for folks,
as,
as imperfect as Wikipedia might be there.
If you search list of cognitive biases,
um,
don't,
don't search cognitive bias search list of cognitive biases.
There's a long list of these types of,
of cognitive biases and they're also a lot of books explore this like think
twice.
Um,
but the,
there's sort of two approaches here,
right?
Or two ways that you can minimize the damage of cognitive biases or extract
value from them,
right?
The first is correcting those cognitive biases are at least becoming aware of
them.
The second is harnessing your inherent cognitive biases for something positive,
right?
It's,
for instance,
um,
there are,
uh,
cases where,
experiments have been done with,
uh,
say gym memberships.
And so having someone pay on a monthly basis for gym membership is not nearly as
effective as say,
having them overpay in advance and then giving them a refund of x amount for
each y number of,
of times they go to the gym.
Uh,
and sort of harnessing that type of prepayment and loss aversion and sunken
costs,
uh,
to,
to incentivize somebody to do something positive they wouldn't otherwise
do.
Um,
so it's a,
anyway,
this,
this is also something that I like to nerd out about.
So yeah.
What's,
what's,
what's a behavioral,
what's a cognitive bias that you,
that you overcame or something that you're currently working on?
Anything in particular?
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
I mean,
I think all of these things were things that all of these things are things that
are very innate in everybody.
Uh,
and so I think,
you know,
I,
I at some point I did have sunk cost fallacy at some point.
I did have a loss aversion and these kinds of things.
Um,
let me see,
what's a big one that I think another big one that everyone has,
this is anchoring and I certainly had that before,
which is,
uh,
you know,
in a,
in a negotiation when,
uh,
when it's not clear,
like what the price for something should be,
uh,
you should,
you should just throw out a huge number.
Like,
like,
okay,
like you said,
like if you wanted me to be,
if you wanted me to be your mentor or,
right.
And so it looks at an hourly rate be between you and me.
Like I have,
like,
I have no idea.
Like I don't,
I've never taught like,
you know,
for,
uh,
for a living and,
so we'd have no idea.
You and I,
so in that silent moment when,
when you and are like,
what do you think the price should be?
Uh,
I'm going to blurt out $1,000 an hour.
That's what I'm going to say.
Right.
And is that because I think I deserve that?
It's because now I've anchored the conversation saying a huge number like that,
uh,
has,
has like blown away.
You're like,
it's destroyed.
Like your brain,
I've just destroyed your brain.
It's not hard.
And so,
right.
And so now when we settle on a,
on a final number,
it's going to be much higher than it would have been otherwise.
And that,
that's just a cognitive bias.
And I,
and now like,
like you said,
you use these to your advantage.
This is a situation which I can use that to my advantage.
So,
right.
The final,
especially because,
especially because I suck at math on top of that.
Yeah.
So,
right.
Where's the final,
you know,
if I hadn't done that,
the final price might have been $25 an hour.
Uh,
and since I threw out that huge number,
it's like screwed up your brain now and uh,
and the final prices is instead going to be $40 an hour.
Uh,
because,
because I've done anchoring thing.
And so,
uh,
and so that,
that's a great one.
Uh,
for all you listeners out there,
they go into negotiation,
go try it,
try this,
try this out.
Um,
it's,
it only works when there's a not,
not a,
a preset sort of yeah.
Reference Point,
right?
Like if you're like,
how much,
you know,
how much I'm going to sell you my used a Toyota.
Right?
And how much should it be?
And like,
you know,
a ballpark should be five grand.
I can't be like,
oh,
a hundred grand.
Right.
It just sounds stupid and like rude,
right to be so,
so it only works really when,
when there's not a good expectation from either party,
that that is a good point.
That negotiating is a fantastic way.
That's probably the most systematic way that I've tried to dress my own
self.
Defeating instincts would be another way to look at biases.
Right.
Um,
so the secrets of power in negotiating as a great book,
the audio is even better getting past,
no,
I think it was a fantastic book.
Better than getting to,
yes.
Do you have any,
have you,
have you read any particular books on negotiating or actually
the first book that came to mind for me it was getting to,
yes.
Yes.
Okay.
What I love,
I love getting to,
yes.
And I love,
uh,
you know,
a lot of important things that people would misunderstand.
Uh,
and I've just further that with the example I just said was that not,
not all negotiation is a zero sum game.
Yeah.
I think getting to yes is a great,
is a great,
uh,
you know,
exposition of that.
Yup.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
uh,
I think you'd enjoy getting past,
no,
it was actually written after getting to yes.
By one of the coauthors of getting,
getting to yes.
What a,
when you think of the word successful or hear the word successful,
who's the first person that comes to mind and why?
Uh,
I think I'd say Bill Gates.
maybe that's a cliche,
like sort of obvious answer,
but,
uh,
you know,
it depends on,
it depends on the reasons you give.
I guess he's in Tech,
right?
He is.
Slash was a computer nerd.
I'm a computer nerd.
Uh,
you know,
he built an immense,
and,
you know,
one of the greatest software companies,
uh,
greatest technology companies ever.
Uh,
and something that I aspire to do.
and then not,
you know,
not only that,
but then,
you know,
uh,
sort of the second chapter of his life,
he's now gone and done all this great philanthropy.
Uh,
and it's something that,
you know,
I would,
I would love to follow in his footsteps on that.
When your retirement time comes for me,
is to go and give back and do this philanthropic efforts.
Uh,
if you were to follow Bill Gates Path,
uh,
in a lot of those respects that you just mentioned,
what are the things about Bill Gates?
It,
uh,
if you could opt out of emulating,
you would opt out?
Uh,
um,
I dunno,
I guess,
uh,
it was a tough one.
I guess the,
he could see like,
you know,
I guess he was very rough on his own employees and,
uh,
within,
within Microsoft.
Uh,
and I think that,
uh,
at a younger age I was,
I was also very,
uh,
you know,
very abrupt and sort of,
uh,
you know,
fit to like,
uh,
so susceptible to like bouts of anger and whatever.
Um,
and I think I've come a long way at,
at,
at this company to,
uh,
to be a lot nicer and write it as like,
I had a couple of startups in my twenties and I think I was very sort of
mercurial at,
in those,
in those startups.
But,
uh,
by the time I had started Zoc doc,
and sort of ironed all that out and it's much better to manage,
be nice for some of your management.
I like mercurial.
That's a good adjective.
I was,
I,
it makes me think of a comedian named Jim Gaffigan,
and if you've ever heard of him,
but he said,
he said,
yeah,
you know,
I wish I were,
I think he's,
he,
I think he said at some point,
and I'm paraphrasing,
he was like,
yeah,
you know,
if you're a a Latin guy or woman and you're really angry,
people say,
wow,
it's just that Latin temper.
And he's like,
but if I behaved that way,
people just say,
wow,
that guy's a dick.
Uh,
but a mercurial,
I liked that choice.
Um,
it was just my Indian passion coming through.
Exactly.
I,
I dunno what the,
yeah,
I don't,
I can't pull off Scandinavian passion.
Doesn't,
it doesn't,
uh,
it doesn't usually get accepted.
The,
uh,
so on the flip side,
what's the first face that comes to mind when you think punchable Oh,
Jesus.
Oh,
I dunno.
I don't know.
It doesn't have to be a real person.
I'll give you,
I'll give you an out
jersey shore people,
right?
Or the,
you know,
the sort of people that are,
uh,
you know,
famous for being famous.
Yeah.
Not,
not the people that are,
have actually contributed built stuff and build stuff.
Yeah.
What's the,
uh,
what are the most frequently played albums or artists on your iPhone or
computer?
Uh,
I,
well,
I love the Beatles a lot and I think that the more,
the more I listened to them,
uh,
the more complexity and,
and sort of stuff you discover is as he listens to their stuff over and over,
which is great,
right?
A lot of,
a lot of pop songs are just really simple.
And the first time you heard it,
you've heard everything there is to hair.
Um,
but you,
you know,
and the Beatles early stuff was like that.
Like it was really simple and kind of about like chasing girls and stuff.
Um,
and then later on they,
they got really,
really sophisticated and,
and uh,
you know,
there's a lot of lovely complexity to the music.
And as you know,
I'm a big,
you know,
I play music myself and I understand quite a bit about music theory,
which is,
uh,
you know,
again,
getting sort of mathematical,
but,
uh,
really understanding why things sound good and why this chord sounds great here
in this kind of stuff is all,
uh,
once again,
math and not,
not complicated math,
simple math,
but,
um,
uh,
but I love music theory and,
and,
uh,
you know,
they,
those guys were the kings of that.
What's,
uh,
what would be two or three tracks that you would suggest people listen to,
to explore that?
Uh,
let me see.
if you find,
uh,
let me,
let me think.
Uh,
I like across the universal law.
Um,
so if you buy like you,
you're gonna,
you can even see like,
which once you understand music theory,
which ones were written by whom.
And so you can see,
uh,
like,
Paul Mccartney always plays this.
Uh,
he,
he always puts the four minor in,
in his,
in his songs.
And that's,
uh,
that's sort of a music theory term.
But,
um,
he's a big fan of,
of,
of putting the four minor [inaudible] in his writing.
Uh,
and so you can,
when you're here,
you know,
for minor come up,
you're like,
oh,
I bet this one was written by Mccartney and then you go look at interesting.
Right.
And so,
uh,
I like across the universe,
which does have a four minor in it.
Uh,
I like,
uh,
I like something that's,
that one's by,
I think it's by George Harrison.
Uh,
and um,
let me see what are some other good ones?
Ah,
certainly like the more psychedelic ones like Lucy in the sky with diamonds is
great.
Uh,
I am the Walrus is great and uh,
yeah,
there's really no end to the,
to the list.
Yeah.
If you had a thousand people,
uh,
non musicians,
people who listen to music,
but I've never played an instrument and you want it to get them hooked on.
Yeah.
Learning more about music and potentially playing music.
What would you have them read,
watch,
listen by whether it's an instrument or otherwise.
I mean,
you,
you are,
you are in large part responsible for getting me interested in a hand drawing.
Right.
Um,
but I'm not sure if that's the best gateway drug with music,
but what would you,
what would you have them listen to or buy or play with or do?
If you had a thousand people and you had like $1 million on the line,
I'm not sure what the minimal threshold is for you to,
to make it right.
Oh,
do a business case and say,
I can train this many of,
you know,
uh,
I think that,
probably the guitar is the easiest because I wouldn't have guessed that.
Why?
I think,
well,
for a couple reasons it's not,
it's probably not the easiest to,
uh,
to play in terms of like,
I mean,
you know,
it's kind of hard to hold a chord and obviously with a piano you can just pump
the keys.
But,
um,
but the second you could get over the hump of learning three or four chords on
guitar,
uh,
you're off to the races,
right?
Because you can learn,
you can play so many pop songs,
uh,
with just three or four chords on guitar.
And,
uh,
so within a few weeks you can already start,
be playing,
uh,
you know,
simple songs.
And,
and then like twist and shout for example,
to go back to the Beatles is just three chords,
three easy chords.
Uh,
and so you can play,
twist and shout and you know,
in a week or two really well.
And then,
and then what you do is as you learn each new song,
pick a song with one extra cord in it,
right?
So,
so this next song has the same three chords as twist and shout,
but one minor chord in it.
And so now,
right,
so now you're learning that new song you're leveraging,
right?
75%.
You already know,
cause it's the other three chords,
uh,
and you're only picking up one new chord.
And so then as,
as you play,
you know,
as you pick new songs,
just to add one new court each time,
uh,
on your repertoire,
girls of songs,
you know,
and the repertoire accords,
also grows.
Uh,
and it makes right.
And so it's really easy to get into that groove where it's fun to play because
you're playing songs that everybody likes
and it doesn't feel like work or,
or,
or rehearsal or practice is just,
you know,
each one.
I just have to practice one new cord,
uh,
and over time,
you know,
over the course of a year you'll learn a ton of a ton of songs.
Ned,
the,
uh,
as a couple of resources for,
for folks potentially.
One is,
uh,
just googling axis of awesome,
who I think at or if you've seen this,
does it,
it does an amazing example of showing with three or four chords how you can play
almost every pop song you've ever heard.
Yeah.
But that chord progression,
it's called one,
five,
six,
four.
Uh,
and uh,
there you go.
People could just Google that.
So core progression one,
five,
six,
four.
Music theory notation,
it'd be one,
five,
six,
four,
and then,
and they play like a hundred different songs.
Uh,
and it's really hilarious.
Yeah.
They're,
they're amazing.
Uh,
are there any,
for someone to add one quarter at a time without having to manually figure it
out themselves and kind of reinvent the wheel,
is there any particular approach that you would suggest in doing that?
Any,
any way that you would Google for that to figure it out?
Or a youtube approach or a teachers?
I mean,
yeah,
there's a,
I mean,
there's a extreme wealth of online of,
uh,
you know,
online diagrams and youtube videos about how to do these things.
So,
you know,
search for,
to whittle it down.
I think it's a paradox of choice,
challenge for a lot of people.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I dunno really.
I guess it's not like for the basic chords,
it's,
it's really like any,
anything we'll do,
uh,
you know,
for example,
uh,
a d major chord is just,
you know,
it's three of your fingers,
your index,
middle and fourth finger,
uh,
and then you have to put them on the bottom three strings of the,
of the guitar on the Second Fret,
third Friday and second fret.
And so you just have to,
you know,
it's just that it's not more complicated than that.
There's no like specific,
uh,
you know,
form that you have to do when you approach the guitar,
whatever.
You just got to slam your three fingers down on those three frets,
on those three strings and you'll play a d chord.
And so at that level,
uh,
you know,
you just need to know which fingers to put on which strings where,
and it's not,
you know,
it's not an intense sort of,
yeah.
You know,
form,
exercise or anything.
Cool.
All right,
last question for now.
In this installment,
uh,
if you could give your 20 year old self advice at this point in retrospect,
what would it be?
And it doesn't have to be one thing.
Oh Man.
Uh,
or just 20 year olds in general could be you yourself,
but it could be in general.
Sure.
I mean,
I guess it would go back to these.
Uh,
so I'd say certainly,
um,
when you're young,
do,
do the things,
do the entrepreneurial things,
because those are the things that will get you,
uh,
you'll,
you'll learn the most by far.
And so I did,
like I said,
I did two startups in my twenties,
and they were,
you know,
that neither one was a great hit.
Uh,
but,
um,
but the amount I learned in one year of doing a startup was like,
you know,
it was like seven years of working at a,
at a,
you know,
at a big company.
And so,
you know,
when you're young and you know,
you just finished college or whatever and you've got this,
uh,
you know,
you've got this freedom and you're not encumbered with,
uh,
you know,
with a spouse and kids that you have to,
that you have to pay for.
Uh,
and you can live on ramen noodles.
And all this stuff,
that's the time to go and take this entrepreneurial risk because you,
even if everything you do is a complete flop,
uh,
you know,
if you spend five years doing it,
you will have learned like 35 years worth of,
of,
you know,
career progression in life skills,
uh,
in those five years of,
of,
of just risking and failing and risking and failing.
So even if it's a total flop,
they,
the person that you come out at the end of it,
uh,
as,
as is,
is far ahead of if you'd just gone and worked at a big company.
So on that,
on that point,
I lied about the last question.
This is more for people who are graduating now or considering a,
a shift,
a career change.
Uh,
I'm not sure if this is age dependent,
but let's just say for the sake of argument that they're,
they're single or they just have very low burn rate,
what would,
how would you suggest people choose their first Gig or their next gig?
I know it's a highly personal thing,
but let's,
let's just say people graduating college in the near future for the sake of
simplicity.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's just like figure out a market need,
like anything that you have in your day to day world,
uh,
you know,
that that sucks.
Like what is,
you know,
is it hard to find parking or can you,
it was a movie theater,
dirty or whatever,
and,
and just try to solve that problem.
Uh,
and,
you know,
I,
I think that's a great way to get started.
And you know,
you'll learn a lot.
You'll do something,
uh,
you know,
you'll,
you'll create a website where it shows you like,
which movie theaters are dirty and you'll realize,
wow,
I can't,
like,
there's no revenue from this website.
Like,
I can't,
I can't make any money telling people what movie theaters a dirty.
But then that's a learning by itself,
right?
And,
and,
you know,
and you come away from that and you're like,
okay,
I need to think about,
you know,
things with actual revenue opportunities.
And you'll do that iterative process and you'll,
you know,
you'll flop a bunch,
but that's fine.
Like that's the learning process and you know,
it's the school of hard knocks,
uh,
and you're going to learn a ton just doing that kind of stuff.
Awesome.
Well,
nick,
I think,
uh,
this is,
this is a great place to stop for now.
I'm sure we'll have,
uh,
around two in person with some food and some wine,
but a lot of fun.
Where can people learn more about you or Zoc Doc?
Where would you like people to check?
Uh,
check what's step two out?
Certainly.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I'm on the,
about us page of Zoc Doc,
so,
uh,
but you know,
more importantly,
if you know,
if,
if you need a doctor,
it really is the best place to find a doctor.
So zoc doc z o c d o C.
Dot com.
Uh,
for myself,
I don't,
I mean I don't have any,
I don't have any about,
you know,
like,
uh,
I don't have a shrine to me on the web anywhere.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I've got a linkedin page you can find me on linkedin page I suppose,
but uh,
but you know,
Zoc doc is my,
it was my pride and joy,
so go there.
Awesome.
All right,
well I'm going to,
uh,
I'm going to,
I'm going to cut my teeth on some ping pong and we may have to have a showdown
next time we,
uh,
get together balls of fury style.
Uh,
awesome man.
Well thanks very much and I will talk to you soon.
Awesome.
Thanks a lot.
All right buddy.
Bye.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by 99 designs and
ex-officio 99 designs is the world's largest online marketplace of graphic
designers and I have used 99 designs for years,
including to get cover concepts for the four hour body,
which went on to become number one New York Times number one,
Wall Street Journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it works and you can check everything out,
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim
with you need a logo,
a car wrap,
a web design and APP,
a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you love or you pay nothing.
It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work week as a resource.
Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim and if you use that link you'll be able to see
what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99 as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions.
So check it out.
Ex-Officio boy,
where do I begin?
I have a long history with ex-officio.
Ex-Officio makes clothing and as far back as 2007 2008 I had a hit video that
went viral called how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less,
and I talked about ex-officio underwear.
Ex-Officio underwear is lightweight,
ultra lightweight,
quick drying,
an antimicrobial.
Why is this important?
Well,
I've gone through 20 plus countries with two pairs of underwear before,
both from ex-officio,
and I'm not alone in this.
This might sound crazy,
but a lot of executives,
for instance,
we'll take this underwear,
they'll wash it in the sink or somewhere else,
roll it up in a towel,
like a Burrito step on it,
and a few hours later they are completely dry,
completely clean.
You don't have to just have to,
and yes,
they have to be comfortable for all day wear,
but check out their clothing as well as their underwear.
You can go to ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim,
that's x,
o.com forward slash Tim and you can see this video,
which has a bunch of other packing tips,
but this underwear,
this clothing is not just for the gents ladies.
You have choices too,
and they really have an incredible collection of high quality products that I've
used for almost 10 years now.
So check them out.
EX-OFFICIO DOT com forward slash Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.